la première fois soit des deux a été
hospitalisé plus goûté la maladie a vite
attaqué le système respiratoire divan
dès son arrivée à l'hôpital de 15
septembre il a été admis d'urgence ou
soins intensifs
ils m'ont mis pour m'aider à respirer
peut-être qu'elle respire et l'enfant
pendant deux mois la cuve vide joue un
jeu cruel avec yvan certains jours il va
mieux
d'autres fois ses douleurs devienne
insoutenable il est seul à l'hôpital
sans voir ses enfants ni sa femme avec
qui il partage sa vie depuis 45 ans avec
l'aco vide
j'ai pas pu la compagnie
du reste dans la maison puis on n'a même
pas eu une vision à repartir rien
l'angoissent l'espoir et la peur
prennent toute la place pendant les deux
mois d'hospitalisation divan avec
toujours l'impression que la mort le
guette prête à faucher le père de
famille j'en ai vu quatre sortir dans
des pages blanches khartoum sont
agressifs c'est une journée
tranquillement dit la dernière fois que
c'est tout le boulot
on s'en sort c'était le soulagement chez
partout c'est un enfer à vivre yvan est
de retour chez lui depuis le 13 novembre
le début d'une longue convalescence
mais si tous à droite là haut
cette année au milieu des décorations de
noël il y a des inhalateurs un
concentrateur d'oxygène et des
médicaments
ils vendent encore besoin pour respirer
après un effort trop soutenu comme
monter les marches vous parlez trop
longtemps malgré tout noël sera heureux
est en fait un miracle pour qu'on peut
dire ouais enfin d'amérique avec moi et
m'ont battu l'américain rue du cauvel
howie a pas d'autres cadeaux que sa
lancée c'est vraiment
le cadeau idéal à recevoir après tout y
vendait ralentir sa petite fille ici
sébastien tanguay radio-canada saint
gabriel de valcartier